look you're quivering yeah I'm River
don't judge me you eat that I've never
wanted to walk up a set more than now
live and direct from Hollywood its feast
mode hunger squad we're doing this again
we're eating fishes cod sperm it's
actually called Scirocco we're gonna go
to two restaurants that serve the finest
cod sperm in all of Los Angeles I'm
pretty excited I'm sad I have a feeling
that cod sperm is actually delicious
I've also heard that it's pretty good
don't want to eat this step I'm all
about it I'm a 21st century man this
used to be fun we're keeping Nikki in
the dark she has no idea what we're
gonna go eat I still say it but I'm
doing okay I want to hold your
excitement let's roll let's go like used
to eat like fun things like doughnuts it
would be fun okay so we're on our way to
the first restaurant
it's called Shuji I'm still terrified
like wait you're terrified yes
welcome to Shinji thank you we heard a
lot of things about your Scirocco mm-hmm
dear several different kind of Scirocco
depends on the fish but right now we use
cod it's it's a egg of cod mayo egg Oh
God some people call milk cod firm
excited the taste is really good we are
gonna make one dish
it's called chawanmushi she's like a
Japanese egg custard pudding yeah and we
add Shrek oh oh who is warm guys
it definitely looks like sperm it looks
crazy
it looks like a fish beat off into a
cup-like it reminds me of like miso soup
made out of cheese it didn't expect it
to look so much like the real thing yeah
there's a lot in here it's like from one
fish no it's tasty no when I put it in
my mouth it rejects it no it's very much
a mental thing kinda has the exact same
texture its creamy very my old sort of
musky flavor texture would get a spin
because it's is that identical to like
the real thing
I feel mildly horny probably a 5 out of
10 there I feel like my Cod maybe had
some pineapple before I got busy
straight taste I would say it's like an
8 mm Robyn ain't yours
ready clean plate Club around - now
we've tried cod sperm we're going to
compare it to another place and we're
going to a place called Thomas Hawkins
we'll see with this next place a
three-story today we're kind of like
going around LA and trying to find the
best cod milk do a lot of people order
that here yes last time we sold out so
that's all I mean certain days we do
sell out oh wow man who comes out I've
been doing it three different ways for
you
two of them they're gonna be cooked and
ones it be wrong we're about to dive in
let's do it yeah we're ready tempura
style guys outsides great insides it
kind of gave me the vibe of an oyster
what is the texture fried come ball
creaminess is on fleek tempura style is
better this is how you get kids to start
liking
Wow Wow smells like Christmas and that
was literally an explosion of flavors in
my mouth that was really good
tens across the board on every flavor
possible like a little bit of guacamole
and the fig I thought the fig was a nice
touch it was great
that [ __ ] was fancy and [ __ ] might be a
little melted out it's you know we got
the raw coming right it's just like it
does it in yeah that caught me off
masters yeah the ultimate boss you can
see like veins honestly and truly at
this point guys I might have select
about you've come this far there's one
left
look your quiver okay on the river don't
judge me you eat that go Steven come on
that was barely a bite one side a fallen
hole because I can't I can't
Steven we all did it Rahl is not my
thing
even come on Stephen come on Eve it whoa
super coming uh ah cod sperm you can't
judge that no rubric here this husband
was next to levels after you for
inviting me
I have never wanted to walk up a set
more than now I can't pick a favorite
baby come on I don't think I'm tired but
I'm emotionally troubled I'm glad that
the journey was a experience yeah I
don't drive people who eat this stuff I
just it's just not to me his kids this
has been Steven Freddie Nicky and Colin
we out which we do next time I feel
hunger squad let's go